we're in the midst of the great upheaval
our culture is moving so fast in such
strange and unexpected directions that
the world of the near future will be a
mysterious place beyond our
comprehension so remember where you were
when you first heard this my friends
where it is the heralding of a new age
psychologists are now saying it's
totally cool
to masturbate at work all right
according according to a new report the
occasional work jerk or break room fiend
poke can lead to higher productivity
decreased aggression and if you don't
wash your hands there's no better power
move in a slightly sticky handshake well
that's what that was
I've been doing a little work in my
cubicle but that's her voice so
comedians if this trend becomes a trend
what's a professional way to tell your
boss you're going for some workday
self-love al Madrigal I'm gonna take a
long lunch in the handicap stall all
right all right points
[Music]
Clark Duke well actually as an actor you
know we already have a way to tell our
bosses that we're doing that we just say
I'm going to my trailer yeah okay points
fine every time that's what that means
all right on my break I'm gonna go out
and flick my coffee bean if anyone wants
to come all right boy
[Applause]